hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga today we're going to be diving
into the world of hunter hunter in order
to discuss some of the greatest men
users in the series however before we
get into things proper I'd very much
like to clarify what I mean by the top
five men uses specifically in relation
to power I'd like to note that this is
not a list detailing the top five
strongest characters in the series it is
specifically focusing on how characters
use nen in creative and ingenious ways
to achieve their varying goals so to
illustrate an important example you are
not going to see Mero M appear on this
list today
that's because despite being quite
possibly the strongest character this
series will ever have to offer when you
think about it he really is a pretty
poor an end user I mean the large
majority of the HUD su that he does
engage in were innovated by His Royal
Guards and the one original one he does
have - his name is just the ability to
absorb his guards he really is all about
brute force otherwise and that's just
not quite what we're looking for here
today but with that caveat out of the
way let's begin welcome to the top five
nen users in hunter hunter number five
Hisoka so despite his notoriety it may
be a bit of a surprise to see his haka
being placed this high up in the realm
of nen users but I certainly believe
that he has earned it his primary hasu
Bungie gun is extraordinarily simple on
paper basically allowing him to make his
or her all elastic and sticky now when I
first discovered this going through the
series I was kind of underwhelmed at
that explanation but I was very very
quickly won over because this Hart Zoo
is one of the most versatile expressions
of nen we have ever seen in hunter
hunter of course you saw his primary
uses in the world of combat where Bungie
gun works is a phenomenal offensive
utility allowing him to use it as
anything from a basic flail type weapon
to a complicated series of traps
designed for his immediate victory once
sprung in terms of defense Bungie gum is
even crazier with seemingly no force
capable of penetrating it entirely thus
making it something of an ultimate
shield as well as a nice counter-attack
when enemy projectiles are sent flying
back towards their helpless masters and
while he soccer does have another
hatsune on his texture surprise which he
generally uses to procure a
psychological advantage it really is his
extraordinary master of bungee calm that
lands him on this list because the mad
jester was also able to command its
power to achieve the teeny tiny ability
of being able to resurrect himself after
death
Hisoka truly is a dangerous and
terrifying existence and it's avec
of how masterfully he makes use of nen
number four is radnik yep next up we
have the fourth Prince of the cocoon
Empire and the man with quite possibly
the hardest and most annoying name to
pronounce in the series which is
incredible because hunter hunter bow is
complicated and ever conflicting
romanization z' of many many characters
but here we are however if there was one
end user in this world who I would
define as more of a terrifying existence
than Hisoka
it is indeed this man sir I'd Nick is
far and away one of the most gifted ninh
uses the series has ever provided us
with so much so that the words prodigy
and genius are quite possibly not even
strong enough to delve into his pure
affinity for engaging in nen to
demonstrate this natural ability stride
Nick went from not knowing anything
about nan whatsoever to completely
mastering its basic principles
developing an extraordinary hut su and
even unconsciously summoning a powerful
men beast all within a handful of days
and just to expand on his heart to a bit
more it is known as parallel future
which allows rynek to look 10 all
seconds into the future without any time
passing in the present that is unless he
exceeds at 10 seconds in which case he
continues to see 10 seconds into the
future but time in the real world begins
running in parallel to the vision it's a
it's a complicated little system but
extraordinarily powerful and destroyed
Nick's control and the fact that he was
able to figure out his heart too in such
detail in a ridiculously short amount of
time goes to show what a stupidly
amazing nen user he is and to be honest
the only reason why he lands this far
down the list is because we've only
barely begun to see him in action should
hunt on to one day complete the
succession walk and land on the Dark
Continent I'm sure we'll have a much
better idea of where to place right Nick
but for now I'm afraid that the 4th
prince will have to settle for a rather
appropriate fourth place number 3 Zeno's
olden the second transmuter to appear
here today and the former head of the
zoldak family as well as nen user
extraordinaire Zeno's abilities first
garnered prominence in the series when
he and his son Silva took on Carla
Lucifer at which point Xena displayed
the ability to transmute his aura into
the shape of a detailed dragon head
which in the Chimera ant arc would go on
to be shown as an entire dragon by
dipping into the wonders of omission as
well furthermore his skill in
maintaining such a gigantic or construct
extends to him being able to sustain
their existence even when they are
several kilometres away however despite
this grant powers Ino is a Master
Assassin and to thus has honed his
destructive Nan powers to a fine art
form really being extended in the most
strategic and efficient
to manners however showed a more
devastating option be required for a
specific job in xeno is certainly
capable of that as well with one of his
signature techniques being the wildly
deadly dragon dive whereby Xena
maneuvers his nan dragon above a target
and then proceeds to shatter it into
hundreds of smaller dragons resulting in
a reign of Nan hell upon whoever is
unfortunate enough to have enemies
willing to pay the zoldak family or the
use of this ability number 2 krol Oh
Lucifer now we have the second
specialist appearing on this list can
calling this particular individual
special in an ironic way of course is a
grand understatement chroma is perhaps
the most versatile known user we have
ever seen and his abilities stem pretty
much entirely from a single conjured
book known as skill hunter of bandits
secret which allows him to quite
literally steal the nen abilities of
others of course such an incredible
ability comes with a ton of conditions
for activations for to be precise which
are that he must see his victims ability
with his own eyes you must then ask
about said ability and be answered by
the victim then his victims pom needs to
touch the handprint on the book and
finally all of this needs to be
accomplished within a mere hour pretty
restrictive eh well top it all off
crawler needs to keep the book open at
the page of the ability he wishes to use
in order to keep it active although he
can circumvent this by using
double-faced Ihnen bookmark that allows
him to save his page or ability even
when the book is closed and furthermore
if he places the bookmark on the page
and then moves to another well then he
is capable of using two stolen abilities
at once but these restrictions are
pretty maddening and in the hands of a
lesson in user it would make them Nayan
useless but crawler masterfully weaves
and achieves these conditions to make
him an extraordinary user capable of
combating at least two of the previous
contenders on this list managing to kill
one of them and taking on the other in a
two versus one scenario so this man is
the real deal when it comes to net
however there is still one character in
the series who Trump's him but before we
get to that I feel like some honorable
mentions are in order starting out with
maja zoldak and look he has been said to
be extremely powerful but without having
seen much of him it's more or less
impossible to judge his candidacy here
similarly we have Jing freaks who has
actually been labelled as one of the top
five modern and uses in the world in the
series making his exclusion on the
system but once again it's just too hard
to judge based on what little he has
displayed so far then there's also
silver zoldak who may very well be
stronger than his father Zeno as he is
the head of the Tzadik family now but
apart from a big old pair of balls he's
difficult to classify here as well
and finally marijuana oh gods each of
whom possess exceptional reservoirs of
nen and certainly use it more creatively
than Mara when him self but they're just
not quite as versatile as anyone I've
labeled so far except for maybe Pete oh
what a stretch
who was able to engage in post-mortem
nen but would these honorable mentions
out of the way let's get on to number
one
Isak natural having more or less
eliminated everyone else who could have
held the spot in one fell swoop I doubt
that the selection came as a surprise to
most of you they come on this man is the
undisputed master of Nan and in his
prime he even held the title of the most
powerful nin user to go along with it
Natura is a natural enhancer although he
has demonstrated exceptional mastery
over manipulation omission conjuration
and potentially even transmutation all
through his absurdly godlike Otsu the
100 type Guanyin Buddha Vista where in
netzarim it so conscious a gigantic
statue of guanyin
capable of performing 101 different
actions all of which need to be
activated by netra making a prayer
motion however due to his inhuman speed
this process can be achieved in point
one of a second as a result the sheer
versatility of the near infinite
combinations available to Natura he
becomes practically impossible to
overcome in combat I mean unless you
have some sort of invincible ant king
but I mean how many people are
invincible and kings I ask you not you
not you not you do right you but
certainly not you look at this point in
the lifespan of hunter hunter I'm not
sure we'll ever see an end user capable
of stealing the crown from natori his
usage is just far too out-of-this-world
far and above any that would dare call
themselves his contemporary or the next
generation of geniuses and that is why
Isaac Metro lands in the number-one spot
on this list but that pretty much does
it for the top five nine users in Hunter
hunter if you enjoyed this video and the
content this channel produced in general
and please do consider donating to the
new world review patreon because the
support of all of your amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
stardom please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
helps support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server by a wide array of
shenanigan Ori takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your own phenomenal nen users in the
series this has been the new world
review and I'll see you next time
you
and just to expand on his heart so a bit
more it's known as parallel future which
allows Shraddha Neath oh my good and
just to expand on his heart so a bit
more it's known as parallel future which
allows Shraddha knew this name is going
to kill me right niche it's right Nick
shred Nick shred Nick sir ride niche so
right Nick that's definitely Nick sure I
think I mean this is why we can't have
another anime because your name is
unpronounceable producers took one look
at this character and went no too much
effort we'll just adapt something else
instead so writing ink so right Nick
also read Nick oh my god all this time
I've been saying so right Nick could
very possibly be sorry Nick sorry Nick
Harrod Nick shreds you know I've made my
choice and just to expand on his heart
so a bit more it's known as parallel
future which allows she
Fah